this video is made possible by
brilliance you're gonna learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now you get a brilliant at org
forward slash by graphics you'll also
find a link in the description below
Archimedes was the ancient Greek
inventor and mathematician who is
remembered for being one of the greatest
minds in all of human history
his theorems became laws of physics and
his equations became essential for
future generations of scientists and
engineers while his great passion in
life was the study of geometry
Archimedes also used his mind to invent
weapons of war that successfully
defended the city of Syracuse from Roman
invaders on today's by graphics we tell
the story of a man whose legacy has
lasted for thousands of years
[Music]
Archimedes was born in 287 BC in the
city of Syracuse which is located on the
east coast of the island of Sicily he
was the son of finance he was a renowned
mathematician and astronomer when he
completed his basic education in Sicily
Archimedes travelled to Egypt to
complete his education at the time the
city of Alexandria was known for being
one of the greatest places to receive an
education in the entire world of course
not everyone can afford to send their
child to Egypt for school which leads
people to believe that he may have
descended from nobility many scholars
claim that he was a relative of King
Harry on the second who was the ruler of
Syracuse at that time when Archimedes
returned to saira ques after completing
his education he arrived with the object
that is credited as one of his first
inventions this was known as the
Archimedes screw the scholars believe
that Archimedes could have borrowed the
idea from something that had already
existed in Egypt but bringing it to
Greece truly revolutionized life that
people living in Syracuse this was a
spiral-shaped device that could be
placed into a river or a dish of water
runs when you turn the handle water
travels uphill this made it incredibly
easy to fill a bucket with water and to
drain and underground well or ditch the
device is now named after him it would
later be used to water the Hanging
Gardens of Babylon which became one of
the seven wonders of the ancient world
the Archimedes screw is so efficient
that it is still sometimes used to
irrigate fields to this very day aside
from these details of his achievements
we don't know very much about the
personal life of Archimedes he actually
did give the details of his life to his
friends and biographer Heraclitus but
the text was lost over the course of
time we don't even know if he was a
married or had any children but the
stories of his greatest achievements
were passed down through the years which
is how they survived
to this day many of these stories seem
sort landish that they are often debated
and some historians consider them to be
legends at the very least we do know
Archimedes personality according to
Greek biographer Plutarch Archimedes was
so hyper focused on his work that it
became the most important thing in his
life he often forgot to take care of his
basic human needs Archimedes would
forget his food and neglect his person
to the degree that when he was
occasionally carried by absolute
violence to bathe or have his body
anointed he used to trace geometrical
figures in the air
of the fire and diagrams in the all on
his body he was in a state of entire
preoccupation and in the truest sense
divine possession with his love and
delight and science one of the most
famous stories about Archimedes is that
of the golden crown this story was
originally recorded during the first
century BC by a Roman architect named
Vitruvius it's based on a tale that had
been passed down for generations by word
of mouth it has been retold again and
again ever since as the story goes a
local goldsmith in Syracuse was
commissioned to create a golden wreath
crown out of pure gold these crowns were
placed on the heads of the statues of
the Greek gods and goddesses in order to
pay tribute to them however once King
Harun got the crown back he was
surprised by its weight he believed that
the Goldsmith possibly swindled him out
of some of his gold by creating the
crown using silver and then plating it
with gold however he had no way to prove
it without damaging the crown Archimedes
was given the task of figuring out if a
golden crown was truly made of pure gold
or if it was simply gold plating on a
cheaper metal after he was given the
problem to solve he became obsessed with
this since this was all he could think
of day and night he would write down
mathematical equations without positive
results just like always he stopped
eating sleeping and bathing while he
tried to solve the problem eventually
his students dragged him to the bath
house to clean himself because he was
beginning to seriously wreak
when he laid down in the bath some of
the water splashed over the edge of the
tub he realized that the weight of his
body dispersed the water and the excess
had to leave the tub in order to
accommodate his body suddenly he
realized that he could use this to solve
the issue of the golden crown apparently
was so excited by this discovery there's
he jumped out of the bathtub and ran
down the streets shouting Eureka I have
found it without ever bothering to get
dressed people gasped and covered their
children's eyes while others laughed at
the eccentric genius that they all knew
and loved some historians believe that
the last part was exaggerated and that
it may have just been a silly story
that's told for fun even so the practice
of shouting the phrase yury here after a
huge discovery is still used today for
trivia throat the solution with
occurred when he stepped into his bath
and caused it to overflow was to put a
weight of gold equal to the crown and
known to be pure into a bowl which was
filled with water to the brim then the
gold would be removed in the king's
crown put in in its place an alloy of
lighter silver would increase the bulk
of the crown and equals the ball to wave
a flyer once Archimedes proposed this
solution to the King they compared the
containers of water side-by-side and it
was clear that the Goldsmith had in fact
taken a lot of the gold for himself and
given the King a gold-plated crown Dad
sufficient evidence to find him guilty
of stealing from the King in modern
times there are some scholars who
believe this story has been
oversimplified throughout the years and
that Archimedes may have used a more
complex method in order to figure out
the solution to the golden crown others
say that it was a symbolic story and
that the incidence never happened at all
but what we do know is that these
experiments resulted in the creation of
the Archimedes principle this discovery
would later become a law of physics and
began the basis of fluid mechanics and
it's still used by engineers today now
just before you get into Archimedes
inventions and discoveries let me tell
you about today's sponsored brilliant
brilliant believe that learning maths
science and computer science doesn't
have to be dull to that end they put
together courses that are all about
storytelling interactive challenges and
solving problems is a hands-on approach
that is really an excellent way to learn
and currently they have over 50
interactive courses so look you're
halfway through this video so you're
probably already the curious type of
brilliant can be a great way to expand
that curiosity take it a step further
and understand the world even more for
example you could check out their course
on geometry fundamentals rather
appropriate for today's video where
you'll learn things like anger axioms 3d
geometry coordinates and much more it's
a great introduction into how geometry
is used in the real world
look effective learning is all about
problem solving and brilliance help you
to learn and practice that it's just a
great complement to videos like this
it's all good to learn something here
but take it a step deeper on brilliance
so if you want to support by graphics
and get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in depth and maths and
science courses you can head on over to
brilliant org /bi graphics and you'll
get 20% off their annual premium
subscription and like I said it's a
great way to support the show so let's
get
back to it
throughout his lifetime King here on the
second continued to bring his requests
to Archimedes and he was often
challenged to use his mind to create the
impossible the King commissioned him to
build a vessel known as the Syracuse EF
it was said to have been one of the
largest boats that was ever built in
ancient times and required the same
amount of material that would normally
go into building 60 ships it took over a
hundred men to assemble it over one year
according to this story in motion of
force Ellis the interior of the Syracuse
it was so extravagant it would even
impress people in modern times the boat
was constructed of exotic wood and
marble it had watchtowers staffed with
soldiers statues of the gods fresh water
baths massive dining hall serving the
finest food a gymnasium a library a
temple objects were made of ivory and
gold one of the largest pieces of
original artwork that was commissioned
for the ship was an illustration of the
entire epic of the Iliad along the walls
of the ship that had been and assembled
in mosaic tiles King hereon wanted to do
more than just pleasure cruise along the
coast he plans to take it across the
Mediterranean Sea so the question came
to be well how can something so heavy
actually float
Archimedes figured out the law of
buoyancy and hydrostatics in order to
make it all work the King wanted the
impossible but Archimedes was able to
make it happen yet again without his
calculations and the law of buoyancy
modern-day cruise ships and mega yachts
may not exist once the ship was finally
finished the people of Syracuse
celebrated its completion in nearly 2000
people were allowed on board there was
just one problem it was so large that it
could not fit into any of the harbors of
Syracuse so the king gave it as a gift
Ptolemy the king of Egypt and it was
renamed the Alexandria however after its
maiden voyage from Sicily to Egypt no
one knows what happened to this famous
ship aside from figuring out how luxury
cruise liners can float Archimedes
invented some pretty incredible things
that we still use to this very day like
the law of the lever and balance he told
the king that he could lift any object
in no matter how heavy it was it was
quoted as saying to the king give me a
place to stand and I will move the earth
impressed and slightly skeptical the
King asked CM lifts a ship out of the
sea through a series of cogs and pulleys
Archimedes was able to sit at one end of
the lever and lift a ship that was full
of heavy gear while we take them for
granted today his simple machine
inventions
of the 11 screw were completely
revolutionary and would be essential to
building modern society all of this was
incredibly impressive but his favorite
achievements might surprise you they
were his geometric equations in one of
his publications called method he
explained how he was testing various
levers with geometric shapes he would
see how weights balanced against one
another with the center of gravity
sometimes he would see that something
works but that wasn't enough he needed
to use maths to prove step by step why
it worked these were some of the world's
first geometric proofs Archimedes was so
obsessed with calculating maths problems
that he would carry around a tray of
sand with him so that he could trace
calculations with his fingers one of his
most significant contributions to math
came from his publication called on the
measurement of the circle where he
figured out the ratio of a circles
circumference to its diameter at being
poor
3.14 except rap he worked on calculating
the volume and surface area of various
shapes and objects even created the
system of using exponents to describe
large numbers before this time Greek
scientists would perform an experiments
and draw conclusions from it afterwards
Archimedes would begin with maths first
and then perform experiments in order to
attempt to see what would happen in
reality through this form of
experimentation Archimedes was
responsible for so many theorems that
would eventually be classified as laws
of physics because of this his mind has
been compared to that of Einsteins his
brain was a truly remarkable level of
genius that you rarely see but once in a
lifetime
[Music]
in the 3rd century BC the Mediterranean
Basin was split between the
Carthaginians in the West while the
Greeks were in the East the Romans
controlled Rome of course but they were
getting ready to invade the surrounding
territory to build their empire the
Romans and the Carthaginians fought the
First Punic War from 264 to 241 BC the
war ended with Rome taking victory of
Carthage
this meant that Sicily was now a remin
territory the King Haren ii was able to
maintain peace with Rome and remain an
independent city so long as they paid
tribute in the form of goods this all
changed in 218 BC when the Second Punic
War began in 215 BC King Heron ii died
and king hieronymus became the new ruler
of syracuse he chose to switch the
city's loyalty from Romans became rivals
with Carthage instead clearly this was a
huge mistake from 214 212 BC the city of
Syracuse now had to fend off Roman
invaders now so far in this story you
might think that Archimedes was more of
a nerdy type he was only concerned with
maths if he were to put him in a fight
you wouldn't exactly bet on him but when
the king gave him the task of inventing
unstoppable war machines to fight the
Roman Empire his mind absolutely
delivered Archimedes may have been an
old man in his 70s but his mind was
still as sharp as a tack yet again he
was able to achieve the impossible
he created defense weapons that
successfully defended the city for at
least two years one of his most powerful
weapons was known as the Archimedes claw
the claw was attached to his pulley
system the claw would grab onto the
front of a remand boat lifted up in the
air and drop it back into the sea this
would capsize the ship dumping the crew
and all of its weapons into the
Mediterranean the Roman commander
Marcellus was quoted as saying
Archimedes uses my ships to a ladle
seawater into his wine cups but he
didn't stop there
Archimedes also created both large and
small catapults that were able to blast
holes through Roman ships according to
Plutarch when Archimedes began to apply
his engines he at once shot against the
land forces all sorts of missile weapons
and immense masses of stone that came
down with incredible noise and violence
against which no man could stand for
they knocked down those upon whom they
fell in heaps breaking all their ranks
and files
Archimedes has also been credited for
helping Syracuse use burning
which reflected the sunlight onto the
sails of Roman ships causing them to
catch fire the following scene was
described in a 12th century text called
the book of histories the old man dark a
median struck today kind of hexagonal
mirror and at an interval proportionate
to the size of the mirror he sets
similar small mirrors with four edges
moved by links and by a form of hinge
and made sit the center of the sun's
beams its noontide beam whether in
summer or in midwinter afterwards when
the beams were reflected in the mirror a
fearful kindling of fire was raised in
the ship's and at the distance of a bow
shot he turns them into ashes
the defensive weapons were so successful
that they were responsible for killing
thousands of Roman soldiers so long as
they continued to go after Syracuse that
men were killed by these machines
commands of Marcus Claudius Marcellus
decided that it was futile to attack
Syracuse so they waited until they could
find their perfect moment to conquer the
city by 12 12 BC Syracuse could not
defend itself much longer according to
some historians the citizens of the city
were beginning to starve because they
were surrounded by the Romans and could
not get their supplies this starvation
forced them to surrender according to
others Syracuse refused to surrender and
Archimedes his weapons were strong
enough to hold them off but the Romans
they managed to take advantage of a weak
spot in one of their lands facing
defensive walls while everyone was busy
celebrating a religious festival either
way finally captured Syracuse and
ultimately won the second Punic War
[Music]
Marcela's Claudius Marcellus knew that
Archimedes was responsible for those
glorious weapons and he knew that he
could be an asset to the Roman Empire
once they captured the city he gave
strict orders that this genius was an
asset and must not be harmed
he gave the order to bring Archimedes to
him the only issue was that the Roman
soldiers had no idea what Archimedes
looked like now the finer details of the
story of his death changed depending on
the source and what we do know is that
Archimedes was in the middle of working
on his geometry on the beach he was
tracing images of circles and
mathematical equations in the sand a
Roman warrior walked over the top of his
geometric drawings which scattered all
of his work Archimedes was outraged and
seemed to be totally oblivious to the
fact that this was a Roman soldier
according to legend his last words well
do not disturb my circles before being
cut down by the man's sword it was 75
years old after his death Archimedes was
buried in a large tomb that represented
his mathematical achievements even
though he destroyed so many Roman ships
they still had a tremendous amount of
respect for him and scholars would pay
homage to his great mind at the tomb
there was a statue of a sphere and
cylinder this represented why Archimedes
considered to be his greatest
achievement
if a sphere is inscribed in a cylinder
than the it's fear is 2/3 of the
cylinder in both surface area and volume
years later the famous Roman statesman
named Cicero wrote that he wanted to pay
his respects the tomb of Archimedes
after searching for hours he finally
found it in Syracuse it was overgrown
with vegetation and it was clear that no
one had bothered to visit in a very long
time
Cicero cleans the air Aaron wrote down
the inscriptions that he found on the
tomb so that it would never be forgotten
to history in modern times people have
theories as to where the location of the
tomb might be but no one knows for sure
in 1960s the hotel panorama claims that
there discovered the tomb of Archimedes
during construction and that they
preserved it in that courtyard however
some people believe that this was just a
publicity stunt to attract more guests
the hotel years after his death the
works of Archimedes have been rewritten
passed down by scribes over and over
again as tragic as it sounds there must
be countless numbers of notes and texts
that Archimedes created from his
lifetime of work and
they've been lost or destroyed over time
even though it was nearly impossible to
find one of these missing original texts
it did happen in 1906 a lost work known
as the Archimedes palimpsest was
discovered buried in old Christian texts
way back in 12 29 ad a man named
Johannes Moranis was reusing parchment
from old books and he unwittingly
covered up the original work of
Archimedes and replaced it with prayers
in 2008 the text was purchased by its
present owner who was open to the idea
of allowing it to be dissected for
research purposes the group called the
Friends of Archimedes got together to
restore the third codex a team from a
variety of different professional
backgrounds spent over four years
restoring the manuscripts one of the
scholars William Knoll explains in his
TED talk that they had to go through a
painstaking process of removing glue and
examining the pages one by one and a
various light sources in order to reveal
the hidden works this group did not do
this project for the money but rather
for the love of knowledge and out of
respect for Archimedes as mind they
believed that this information should be
free to the public so they made the
entire third codex available to read
online for free the only catch is that
you need to know how to read in ancient
Greek the odds that we will find more
discoveries like this a slim to none but
the works that we do remember from
Archimedes have been enough to
revolutionize modern-day maths science
and engineering without his brilliant
minds the world truly would be a very
different place so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos four times a week hit
that Bell as well that lets you know
when we actually put out a video that's
a good thing and as always thank you for
watching
you
[Music]